(techno music)
- I'd like to tell you about
some of the processes that
unfold as the baby brain
grows and develops.
In particular, I'm gonna
focus on the underpinnings of
language, since language
learning impairment is a feature
of so many developmental disorders,
which we're gonna get into later.
So why look at baby brain function?
Because while we watch this
magical unfolding of early
abilities across development
we can begin to answer
some very big questions
including how do early
events of development
influence later cognition
and later competence.
What risk factors during
early development have
consequences for adult
behavior or disorder and how
might that be altered,
and how can very early abnormalities
in the functional organization
of brain networks be causal
in developmental disorders
such as language learning
disorder, autism, or ADHD.
And importantly, how early
might biomarkers be detected,
measured, and perhaps remediated
with non-invasive technologies.
So as newborns, babies can
discriminate the sounds
of every language acoustically,
but not linguistically.
So starting at birth, the
baby's developing brain
is constructing an
acoustic map of the sounds
of his or her native language.
And this gradual process,
perceptual narrowing,
is thought to be completed
by the end of the first year.
Mapping of these acoustic
contrasts is important
because they're salient to
the surrounding language
ultimately allows the child
to respond in a fast automatic
way to the incoming language stream.
And it's problematic
if this doesn't go well
because it impacts mounting
of fluent native language,
as well as cognition and later
reading due to difficulties
in what's called
phoneme-to-grapheme mapping,
that is matching speech sounds to letters,
which you need to do to read.
Efficient processing of basic
auditory events in the tens
of milliseconds domain called,
rapid auditory processing,
is critical to mounting language
in normative development
and allows the most optimal
acoustic maps to be constructed.
And this is because many speech
sounds, phonemes like da or
ta, only differ by brief
spectral and/or temporal changes
specifically within the
tens of milliseconds.
And differences in these basic
acoustic processing abilities
have been shown to be
related to both concurrent
and later language learning difficulties.
Research from my lab strongly
suggests that the ability
to perform these very fine
acoustic discriminations
within speech or non-speech,
because we mainly look
at prelinguistic non-speech,
is critically important
in normative language and
it may go awry in a subset
of developmental disorders.
Moreover, these skills predict
language outcomes through
early pre-reading and have
an impact on later learning.
So many of our studies,
we examine populations
at higher risk for various
disorders as a consequence
of a child being born into a
family with such disorders.
And heritability studies suggest the risk
can be 30 to 60 percent higher
depending on which disorder
and which study.
So how do you measure
brain responses in infants?
You can use electroencephalography,
EEG, which reflects
the summation of the
synchronous activity of millions
of neurons that have
similar spacial orientation.
You can also use brain
evoked related potentials.
And this is an average across many trials
to generate an averaged waveform
that is time-locked to
external stimulation.
This permits examination
of the time course
in the brain areas related
to sensory processing.
And you can compare and contrast
group response as well as
compare individual
responses to group norms.
Research suggests that brain
oscillations, which are cyclic
fluctuations of the membrane
potential in brain cells,
control neuronal excitability,
integrate sensory inputs,
and may coordinate higher level functions,
such as language memory and learning.
However, neurodynamics was just beginning
to be studied in the human infant.
Our previous studies and
pilot data strongly suggest
that oscillatory dynamics
and their hierarchical
organization have a developmental timeline
and may capture disruption
in normative development.
So how can you look at that?
You can look at the EEG
and you can do something
called a fast Fourier analysis.
This is one way of doing it,
which breaks the EEG pattern
down into its component frequencies.
Synchronized neural oscillations
in these low frequencies,
delta, theta, and alpha
are thought to provide
key mechanisms that orchestrate
network coordination
during development and may be involved
in information transfer among brain areas.
Theta oscillations in
particular are important
for perceptual and
cognitive functions such as
declarative and episodic memory,
and have been proposed
as a neural mechanism
subserving phonemic discrimination
which is one of the reasons
we're very interested in it.
Gamma oscillations from
30 to 80 or 90 hertz
may represent synchronized
activity of local neuronal
populations during sensory
and cognitive processes,
but may also, particularly
high gamma, play a role
in coupling of remote cortical areas.
So given that activity in
this gamma frequency has been
linked in humans and animals
to a wide variety of higher
cognitive processes including
attention memory and language,
we first examine power
density in frontal cortex
across the language bursts
in two groups of children.
And I'm going to give
you a few little snippets
of some studies.
We studied the power of spectra
in two groups of children,
with and without a family
history of language learning
impairment, at 16, 24,
and 36 months of age
when this huge burst in language occurs.
We found that individual
differences in frontal gamma power
during rest highly correlated
with concurrent language
and cognitive skills at all ages.
Children with a family history
of language learning impairment
had lower frontal gamma at all ages.
Power was also associated
with the attentional measures.
Children who were observed
as having better inhibitory
control and more mature
attention shifting abilities
had higher power.
We continued to follow this group
and we found that examining
gamma across the language burst
strongly predicted to both cognition
and language at ages four and five years.
We saw that at 16, 24, and
36 months resting gamma
was associated with four-year
language comprehension scores
and word structure and
sentence structure scores.
And at 24 and 36 months
gamma power was significantly
associated with five-year
sentence imitation
which is really important for pre-readers.
36-month gamma power was
also significantly associated
with five-year syntactical skills.
So what's the take home message here?
We believe that the capacity
to generate higher power
in the gamma range at these
crucial developmental periods
may index better modulation of attention,
and allow easier access to working memory,
providing an advantage
for overall development
particularly in the linguistic domain.
We were then interested in
examining oscillatory support
in younger infants.
So using event-related
potential source localization
and a time-frequency analysis
of event-related oscillation.
So from the source we
examine the neural substrates
of rapid auditory processing
in four month olds.
Animal models and adult experiments
suggest that oscillatory
synchrony, and in particular
low frequency oscillations
in the delta and theta
range play key roles
in rapid auditory processing
and auditory change detection.
So we hypothesized that
synchronized activity
of brain oscillations in left
and right auditory cortices
would support rapid frequency
discrimination in infants.
Moreover, we thought that
infant perception of rapid pitch
and timing changes, which is so critical,
should be mediated in part at least
by oscillatory mechanisms.
These issues had not been
looked at in infants at all,
in human infants.
We used two test sets of
stimuli: Speech-like tones,
(beeping tones)
and a control condition that was
out of the speech-like range.
So we found, and this
is a very busy slide,
but I'll walk you through it.
You're gonna see some of
these figures that show pulled
oscillatory power over time,
with frequency on the X-axis,
time on the Y-axis for these
complex tone pairs in the
control rate and in the rapid
rate, the speech-like rate.
And these are for standards,
the background sounds,
these are for deviants,
the ones that change,
and this is the difference
between the two.
Face synchronization is in red,
desynchronization is in blue.
And what we saw was that there
was enhanced phase-locking
to variant tones in both
rate conditions, larger
and faster activation in the
right hemisphere at both rates.
However, left auditory
activity was enhanced
only during rapid rate presentation.
We also gave these babies
a go/no-go behavioral task
at their second visit.
Auditory perception was measured
by the infant's ability to
learn a reward contingency
for a deviant tone in a pair.
And the number of trials it took the baby
to get four out of five
correct was their criterion.
And we did a median split with
faster and slower learners
and what you see is
that tone discrimination
is strongest for the
children who learn faster.
We also saw that slower
learners had smaller power
differences between their
standard and deviant responses.
And this suggests that they
had a lot of difficulty
discriminating one signal from another.
So the takeaway message here
is that local low frequency
oscillatory synchrony
underlies rapid processing
and can robustly index auditory
abilities in young infants.
And recruitment of the left
hemisphere during rapid
frequency change suggests a
difference in the spectral
and temporal resolution of the right
and left hemispheres even
at this very early age.
Moreover, we were able to predict behavior
in a go/no-go task by looking
at oscillatory brainpower.
So the question is, if we
can find deficits so early
in life, can we alter them
using the exquisite plasticity
typical of this early
developmental time period
while infants are setting
up their acoustic mapping?
Can we make the baby a better processor?
And can we see
intervention-specific changes
in the brain waves and
oscillatory patterns
that reflect enhanced processing?
So can we look for some causal mechanisms?
And so we did a study.
We did a couple of studies.
And looking at plasticity
in developing brain
and seeing if active auditory
exposure would impact
pre-linguistic acoustic mapping.
And I'm gonna go through
this pretty quickly,
but the paper's published if you need it.
So we looked at the neural
correlates of acoustic mapping
with dense array EEG/ERP
before and after a six week
interactive progressive
acoustic experience.
We used an operantly-conditioned
go/no-go active paradigm
with an eye-tracking control
so the baby could actually
manipulate the experiment.
And we used a passive control
and a naive maturation control.
And here's the study designed
two longitudinal arms,
one with active training,
one with passive training,
And two, a cross-sectional
sample of children
who were not trained.
So what did they get
when they were trained?
Once a week for six weeks
for six to eight minutes,
the babies were trained on
three different types of paired
stimuli, complex tones,
band-pass noise frequency sweeps
presented at varying ISIs
and varying complexities
using an up-down staircase procedure.
So if the baby got it
right, it got harder.
If they got it wrong, it got easier.
And so they went up and down
until they reached criterion.
The passive group got the same stimuli,
and the same time exposure,
but passive with no feedback
and we didn't train the naive children.
After they were trained, we
collected data on ERPs, EEG
that they had been trained
on, as well as different
types of generalization stimuli.
So we looked at deviance with
spectral temporal parameters
that significantly differed
from the training stimuli,
one with a gap, one with
a differing duration,
and one with frequency.
So what did we see?
Yes, this is a monster figure.
So we're not gonna talk about
the grand average waveforms.
I'm going to just pull out
the information about these
time-locked age-appropriate topograms to,
first of all this P2 peak.
And this is a peak that happens
that's an attentional peak.
And what we see here is around
each topogram if it has a red
box, it means there was
significantly faster latencies.
So the active group was
significantly faster than both
the passive and the naive
groups on this peak.
And then we also were
interested in looking at
what's called the N2 star,
and this is the change
discrimination peak that
happens right before
the baby discriminates the signal.
And it's important because
it's been shown to be
a robust infant predictor
of later language,
So both of the auditory
groups, experience groups,
were significantly faster
than the naive controls,
but the actives had a larger
amplitude compared to both
other groups and showed a left
hemisphere lateralization.
We then looked at the signals
that were a generalization
stimuli, and what you can see
in these bar graphs is the
mean latency of each deviant at each
of the nine electrode sites.
For P1 that's the first
sensory peak that signals
that a stimulus has been perceived.
And what you can see here for
the gap, for the duration,
and frequency, is the active
group was significantly
faster at all nine electrode sites.
So we demonstrated that
while both active and passive
acoustic experience from four
to seven months modulated
non-speech stimuli, active
experience conferred
a significant advantage, that
active experience increased
attention to environmental
acoustic stimuli,
and that faster latencies
were seen for the change
discrimination peak that
has been shown to be
a robust infant predictor
of later language.
Moreover, we saw
generalization to both trained
and untrained stimuli over and above
that seen for maturation alone.
And do these intervention
effects generalize to language?
I can just say yes, because I think we're
just about at the end.
But just let me show you this high gamma.
At nine months we continued to
look at them longitudinally.
And you can see that for the
actives you have this very high
gamma input here which is a
prominent characteristic of
early sensory processing and
may index cortical activation
given larger high, but not
low gamma responses are
correlated with increases
in overall firing rates
particularly during
attentional modulation.
And with that I'll show you our prototype
that does the same intervention
in the baby's home.
(applause)
And that's the end, thank you.
(techno music)